Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Whenever Darren Lopez heard the song What Might Might Have Been, by country music band Little Texas, his mind wandered and he began to reminisce. In the song, the narrator laments to a former romantic partner about the fact that he cannot change the past and there's no way of knowing what their relationship might have become.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。每当达伦·洛佩兹（Darren Lopez）听到乡村音乐乐队Little Texas的歌曲《What Might Have Been》（曾经可能发生的事）时，他的思绪就会飘远，开始陷入回忆。在这首歌中，叙述者向一位前伴侣感叹，他无法改变过去，也无法知道他们的关系本可能会变成什么样。
Darren was drawn to the thoughtful lyrics which included lines like, We could sit and talk about this all night long and wonder why we didn't last. Yes, they might be the best days we will ever know, but we'll have to leave them in the past. Darren first heard what might have been in 1996 after returning home from military deployment in South Korea. The song evoked happy memories of his youth in Arizona, specifically of his high school sweetheart, Jennifer Nichols. The pair had met when they were both 15 in their school's jazz band and maintained a mutual friendship for several years until a three-week-long school trip to Europe brought them closer together. By the end of that first week, Darren and Jennifer were officially boyfriend and girlfriend.
达伦被那些深情的歌词所吸引，其中包括这样的台词：“我们可以坐下来彻夜长谈，想知道为什么我们没能走到最后。是的，这可能是我们所能拥有的最美好的日子，但我们必须把它们留在过去。”达伦第一次听到这首歌是在1996年，当时他刚从韩国的军事部署中回国。这首歌唤起了他在亚利桑那州度过的青春岁月的快乐回忆，特别是关于他高中时的恋人詹妮弗·尼科尔斯（Jennifer Nichols）的回忆。两人在15岁时相识于学校的爵士乐队，并保持了多年的友谊，直到一次为期三周的欧洲学校旅行让他们走得更近。那第一周结束时，达伦和詹妮弗正式成为了男女朋友。
They shared their first kiss under the Eiffel Tower. From then on, the pair were inseparable. Jennifer admired Darren's politeness, his organisational skills, and the way he made her feel so safe. They attended prom together, Jennifer in a sleeveless red dress and Darren in a suit with a red bow tie to match. As they entered college, they shared hopes that they would one day marry. But it wasn't meant to be. Darren dropped out and followed in his father's footsteps by joining the army. Jennifer opted to stay put and continue pursuing her education in health sciences. education in health sciences. In 1993, as their paths in life naturally deviated, the pair amicably split.
他们在埃菲尔铁塔下献出了初吻。从那时起，两人形影不离。詹妮弗钦佩达伦的礼貌、他的组织能力，以及他让她感到如此安全的方式。他们一起参加了舞会，詹妮弗穿着一件无袖红裙，达伦穿着西装，系着红色的领结与之相配。当他们进入大学时，他们共同怀揣着将来结婚的希望。但事与愿违。达伦退学了，追随父亲的脚步加入了军队。詹妮弗选择留在原地，继续攻读健康科学。1993年，随着他们的人生道路自然分叉，两人友好地分手了。
Years passed with no contact between them, yet anytime Darren heard what might have been, his thoughts turned to Jennifer. He wondered where she was, what she was doing, and who she might be with. Most of all, he truly wished her the best. 2019 wasn't a good year for Darren Lopez. He had separated from his wife, lost touch with friends and barely had any contact with anyone. He was never big on technology and had forgotten the passwords to his long neglected social media accounts.
多年过去了，他们之间没有任何联系，但每当达伦听到《What Might Have Been》这首歌时，他的思绪就会转向詹妮弗。他想知道她在哪里，在做什么，可能和谁在一起。最重要的是，他真心希望她一切都好。2019年对达伦·洛佩兹来说不是好的一年。他与妻子分居了，与朋友失去了联系，几乎与任何人都没有往来。他从不热衷于科技，甚至忘记了他长期闲置的社交媒体账户的密码。
His daughters were mostly grown up and off experiencing life. The younger ones split their time between Darren and his ex-wife, though spent most of their time with their mother. On New Year's Eve, Darren resolved to spend 2020 getting back into life and reconnecting with people. Then the COVID-19 pandemic hit. As lockdowns, quarantines, travel and social restrictions were deployed across the country, Darren grappled with severe loneliness and depression on his isolated ranch. The darker his thoughts became, the more importance he placed on achieving his New Year's resolution by any means possible.
他的女儿们大多已经长大，在外体验生活。年纪较小的女儿们在达伦和前妻之间轮流居住，尽管她们大部分时间都和母亲在一起。新年前夜，达伦下定决心要在2020年重新开始生活，并与人们重新建立联系。然后，新冠疫情爆发了。随着封锁、隔离、旅行和社交限制在全国范围内实施，达伦在他孤立的牧场上饱受孤独和抑郁的折磨。他的想法越阴暗，他就越重视通过任何可能的方式实现他的新年决心。
Darren turned to the internet to reach out to those he genuinely cared for but hadn't seen or heard from in a while. One was his high school girlfriend, Jennifer Nichols. Having lost touch after their breakup in college, Darren was curious to know what Jennifer was up to. After all, she had never been far from his mind. While in the military, Darren had to provide top-secret information that could help confirm his identity if he was ever taken hostage by the enemy. The information had to be extremely personal and couldn't be easily uncovered online or obtained from anyone else. In turn, Darren disclosed fond memories he had of Jennifer Nichols, memories that no one else knew about. Retaining this information during his two decades of active service was paramount for his day-to-day survival. It became ingrained in him and profoundly meaningful. In 2020, Darren searched social media
达伦转向互联网，试图联系那些他真心关心但已有一段时间没见或没听到消息的人。其中一位就是他高中时的女友詹妮弗·尼科尔斯。在大学分手后失去联系，达伦很好奇詹妮弗在做什么。毕竟，她从未离开过他的思绪。在军队服役期间，达伦必须提供绝密信息，以便在被敌人扣为人质时确认身份。这些信息必须极其私密，不能轻易在网上被发现或从其他人那里获得。作为回报，达伦透露了他对詹妮弗·尼科尔斯的珍贵回忆，这些回忆是其他人所不知道的。在二十年的现役生涯中，保留这些信息对他日常的生存至关重要。它已深入他的骨髓，意义深远。2020年，达伦在社交媒体上搜索
until he believed he had finally tracked Jennifer Down on business and employment website LinkedIn. She was no longer Jennifer Nicholls, but Jennifer Faith. On Tuesday March 17, Darren sent Jennifer a brief message reintroducing himself. He received a response within the hour which read, Hi Darren, wow, was I surprised to hear from you. I hope you understand if I am a bit skittish in responding. How do I know this is really you? Darren was elated. He responded, Would it help if I called you Angel? This was the special nickname he'd given Jennifer during the time they were together. He signed off with the quote, As You Wish, which was a line from the
直到他相信自己终于在商业和就业网站LinkedIn上找到了詹妮弗。她不再是詹妮弗·尼科尔斯，而是詹妮弗·费思（Jennifer Faith）。3月17日星期二，达伦给詹妮弗发了一条简短的信息，重新介绍了自己。他在一小时内收到了回复，上面写着：“嗨，达伦，哇，听到你的消息我很惊讶。希望你能理解，如果我在回复时有点谨慎。我怎么知道这真的是你？”达伦欣喜若狂。他回复道：“如果我叫你‘天使’（Angel）会有帮助吗？”这是他在他们在一起时给詹妮弗起的特别昵称。他用“如你所愿”（As You Wish）作为结尾，这是1987年电影
1987 film The Princess Bride, a movie they'd bonded over in the past. Jennifer's response was swift. Yep, that did it. Send me an email and let me know how you are. Excited to talk to you. Darren sent Jennifer a lengthy email filling her in on the past three decades of his life. He thanked Jennifer for teaching him to braid hair as the skill had endeared him to his daughters and their friends.
《公主新娘》（The Princess Bride）中的一句台词，那是他们过去共同喜爱的电影。詹妮弗的回复很快。“是的，这就对了。给我发封邮件，告诉我你过得怎么样。很高兴能和你交谈。”达伦给詹妮弗发了一封长邮件，向她讲述了他过去三十年的生活。他感谢詹妮弗教他编辫子，因为这项技能让他赢得了女儿们和她们朋友的喜爱。
Darren admitted, "...you have no idea how much I have thought of you over the years." He encouraged Jennifer to look up the song What Might Have Been by Little Texas as it made him think of her and always put a smile on his face. Jennifer responded, Wow, my head has been swimming since I read your email this morning. You made my day, month, year, and possibly decade in reaching out to me and saying such nice things. possibly decade in reaching out to me and saying such nice things. Jennifer revealed that she thought about Darren a lot and had searched for him over the years. All she'd been able to deduce was that he was married and lived in Tennessee. You're a hard man to find, she wrote. There are no details out there about you.
达伦承认：“……你无法想象这些年来我有多想你。”他鼓励詹妮弗去听听Little Texas的《What Might Have Been》，因为这让他想起了她，并且总是让他脸上露出笑容。詹妮弗回复道：“哇，自从今天早上读了你的邮件，我的脑子就一直转个不停。你联系我并说了这么多好话，让我这一天、这一月、这一年，甚至这十年都变得美好了。”詹妮弗透露，她也经常想起达伦，多年来一直在寻找他。她所能推断出的只是他已婚并住在田纳西州。“你是个很难找到的人，”她写道，“网上没有任何关于你的详细信息。”
Jennifer told Darren that things hadn't been easy for her after their breakup. After one failed marriage, she swiftly married the next man who came along, a decision she called a huge mistake, as it only lasted nine months. As a single mother, she struggled physically, emotionally, and financially while also completing her college studies and a burgeoning career as a therapist. Then she met her third husband, Jamie Faith, and her life greatly improved. Together with Jennifer's daughter, they formed a happy family. Jennifer excelled in her career and by 2020, she was overseeing therapy programs and assisting new hospital openings across the country. Her daughter was 22 years old and had just completed a master's degree, while Jamie was a big deal at American Airlines.
詹妮弗告诉达伦，分手后她的日子并不好过。在一段失败的婚姻之后，她很快嫁给了下一个男人，她称这个决定是一个巨大的错误，因为这段婚姻只持续了九个月。作为一名单身母亲，她在完成大学学业和作为治疗师的职业生涯起步时，在身体、情感和经济上都苦苦挣扎。后来她遇到了她的第三任丈夫杰米·费思（Jamie Faith），她的生活得到了极大的改善。和詹妮弗的女儿一起，他们组成了一个幸福的家庭。詹妮弗在事业上表现出色，到2020年，她已经在监督治疗项目并协助全国各地新医院的开业。她的女儿22岁，刚完成了硕士学位，而杰米在美国航空公司担任要职。
Jennifer sent Darren a candid happy photo of herself, Jamie and their daughter together, adding, "...I have definitely missed you over the years and there have been so many times I've wanted to talk to you. Thanks for being persistent in looking for me." Darren replied with a recent photo of himself before confessing that ever since Jennifer had responded to his email, he couldn't get her off his mind. The two continued sending each other long emails throughout the day and into the night, catching each other up on every aspect of their lives. They eventually began reminiscing about their high school romance, at which point
詹妮弗给达伦发了一张她、杰米和女儿在一起的坦率快乐的照片，并补充道：“……这些年来我确实很想你，有很多次我想和你说话。谢谢你坚持寻找我。”达伦回复了一张他最近的照片，并坦白说，自从詹妮弗回复了他的邮件后，他就无法将她从脑海中抹去。两人整天整夜地互相发送长邮件，交流彼此生活的方方面面。他们最终开始回忆起他们的高中恋情，此时
the tone of their correspondence became wistful and flirtatious. Darren admitted that Jennifer was making him feel like that teenage boy so many years ago, while she said she was completely giddy. she was completely giddy. By the next day, Darren was overwhelmed with feelings. He wrote an email to Jennifer calling their reunion a great love story. Not wanting her to slip away from him again, he declared, "...I am glad you have had Jamie in your life. It looks like you have made a great family and what you have is unique and special and I don't want to break that up. That being said, I know my heart and you still possess it. I love you." Jennifer confided in Darren that her commitment to Jamie had waned in recent years due to
他们的通信基调变得忧郁而调情。达伦承认詹妮弗让他感觉回到了多年前那个十几岁的男孩，而她说她感到完全头晕目眩。第二天，达伦被各种情绪淹没了。他给詹妮弗写了一封邮件，称他们的重逢是一个伟大的爱情故事。他不希望她再次从他身边溜走，他宣称：“……我很高兴你的生命中有杰米。看起来你已经建立了一个很棒的家庭，你所拥有的东西是独特而特别的，我不想破坏它。话虽如此，我知道我的心，它仍然属于你。我爱你。”詹妮弗向达伦吐露，她对杰米的承诺近年来因
a lack of affection. Darren made it abundantly clear that he was willing to provide Jennifer with the intimacy and romance she desired while taking things as slowly as she needed. Jennifer reciprocated Darren's feelings and within days of reconnecting, the pair began brainstorming a five-year plan for a future together. Jennifer and Darren traded cell phone numbers and as their contact continued, they agreed to permanently delete their texts. However, their email correspondence remained archived in Darren's inbox. His ex-wife came across the emails while Darren was in custody awaiting trial for Jamie Faith's murder. Shocked by what they contained, she immediately sent them to detectives fronting the Faith case. By this point, Darren and DeGeneres' emotional affair had already been
缺乏感情而减弱。达伦明确表示，他愿意为詹妮弗提供她渴望的亲密和浪漫，同时按照她需要的速度慢慢来。詹妮弗回应了达伦的感情，在重新联系后的几天内，两人开始为共同的未来制定五年计划。詹妮弗和达伦交换了手机号码，随着联系的继续，他们同意永久删除他们的短信。然而，他们的电子邮件通信仍存档在达伦的收件箱中。达伦的前妻在达伦因杰米·费思谋杀案被拘留候审时发现了这些邮件。她对邮件的内容感到震惊，立即将它们发送给了负责费思案件的侦探。此时，达伦和詹妮弗的情感出轨已经
exposed. While the emails didn't initially reveal anything investigators didn't already know, it was eye-opening to glimpse the intensity of the pair's mutual affection. But as detectives made their way through the emails, something caught their attention. Three weeks after Jennifer and Darren reconnected, on the morning of Monday April 6, Jennifer sent an uncharacteristically short and sharp email. It read, I can tell Jamie is texting you. Sorry. Before Darren had time to respond, Jennifer sent a follow-up email saying, I love you. I am sorry this has become such a mess. We just need to get through today somehow. Once Jamie starts to believe you're gone, it will be better. I don't know what he is saying,
曝光。虽然这些邮件最初并没有揭示调查人员尚未掌握的任何信息，但窥见两人相互爱慕的强烈程度令人大开眼界。但当侦探们仔细阅读这些邮件时，一些事情引起了他们的注意。在詹妮弗和达伦重新联系三周后，4月6日星期一早上，詹妮弗发了一封异常简短且尖锐的邮件。上面写着：“我看得出杰米在给你发短信。抱歉。”在达伦来得及回复之前，詹妮弗发了一封后续邮件说：“我爱你。我很抱歉这一切变得如此混乱。我们只需要以某种方式度过今天。一旦杰米开始相信你已经离开了，情况就会好转。我不知道他在说什么，
but whatever he is telling you, I am okay. I can handle this if I don't lose you. Please talk to me. I need you." Without access to the texts to fill in the gaps, investigators deduced that Jamie had likely messaged Darren after learning of the emotional affair. They found this surprising as they had already examined data from Darren's cell provider and found no record of any contact between Darren and Jamie's cell phones. Darren nevertheless confirmed the encounter in his reply to Jennifer's email that same day writing, "'I know today has been horrible again. You were being so strong for us. Jamie cannot destroy us, no matter how hard he tries.'" He encouraged Jennifer to keep planning their lives
但无论他告诉你什么，我都很好。只要我不失去你，我就能应付。请和我说话。我需要你。”由于无法获取短信来填补空白，调查人员推断杰米在得知这段情感出轨后可能给达伦发了信息。他们发现这很令人惊讶，因为他们已经检查了达伦手机运营商的数据，发现达伦和杰米的手机之间没有任何联系记录。尽管如此，达伦在当天回复詹妮弗的邮件中证实了这次接触，写道：“‘我知道今天又很糟糕。你一直为我们表现得如此坚强。杰米无法摧毁我们，无论他多么努力。’”他鼓励詹妮弗继续规划他们的生活
together, saying his desire for her had only grown. As far as Darren was concerned, there was nothing Jamie could do to change his feelings for Jennifer. He signed off. Nothing can keep me from you. Angel, I am your rock, your solace. I am here, always. Later that same day, Darren emailed Jennifer to say, Later that same day, Darren emailed Jennifer to say, Jamie started texting again, if you decide to stay with Jamie you need to know what you are up against. Darren claimed that Jamie had lost his mind and had fucked up thinking. He told Jennifer, for some reason us together has shattered Jamie in ways neither of us could have imagined. Darren offered to help Jennifer leave her marriage, though accepted that the decision was hers to make and he would stand by her regardless. He professed,
在一起，说他对她的渴望只增不减。就达伦而言，杰米无法做任何事情来改变他对詹妮弗的感情。他写道：“没有什么能让我离开你。天使，我是你的磐石，你的慰藉。我一直在这里。”当天晚些时候，达伦给詹妮弗发邮件说：“杰米又开始发短信了，如果你决定和杰米在一起，你需要知道你面临的是什么。”达伦声称杰米已经疯了，思想已经扭曲。他告诉詹妮弗，出于某种原因，他们在一起的事实以一种我们谁都无法想象的方式击垮了杰米。达伦提出帮助詹妮弗离开她的婚姻，尽管他接受这是她自己的决定，无论如何他都会支持她。他宣称：
I love you, I am still here, and this does not scare me away. I am here with you through all this, right by your side through this darkness. We will find the light and come out together even stronger with each other." At no point in the emails between Darren and Jennifer did they address what Jamie had done that had left them so rattled, but things appeared to have escalated that night. According to an email from Darren, Jamie said he had one final test for Jennifer. If she passed it, she would get her life back. Darren wrote, she passed it, she would get her life back. Darren wrote, He plans on taking you somewhere. Has he talked about other men being with you?
“我爱你，我仍然在这里，这并不能吓跑我。我会陪你度过这一切，在这黑暗中一直守在你身边。我们会找到光明，并以更坚强的姿态共同走出困境。”在达伦和詹妮弗的邮件中，他们从未提及杰米做了什么让他们如此不安，但那天晚上事情似乎升级了。根据达伦的一封邮件，杰米说他给詹妮弗准备了最后一次考验。如果她通过了，她就能找回她的生活。达伦写道：“他打算带你去某个地方。他有没有谈过让其他男人和你在一起？”
He has told me he would let others use you. Just want you to know what he said to me. I just want you to be prepared. We will get through this. I am forever your true love. will get through this. I am forever your true love." To investigators, it sounded like Jamie had told Darren of his intentions to have other men sexually assault his wife. As absurd as it sounded, Jennifer and Darren seemed genuinely terrified and an attack appeared to have gone ahead. attack appeared to have gone ahead. Darren later wrote to Jennifer, I was with you through it all. You did so good. He really thinks he broke you and has driven me off. We beat him. Darren suggested they fast-track their five-year plan so Jennifer could get away from Jamie sooner. In the meantime, the pair came up with a plan to start their text messages with the code 575. This way, Darren would know he was talking to Jennifer and not Jamie. Based on this information, investigators deduced that Jamie had been
“他告诉我他会让别人使用你。我只是想让你知道他对我说了什么。我只是想让你做好准备。我们会度过难关的。我永远是你真诚的爱人。”对调查人员来说，这听起来像是杰米告诉达伦他打算让其他男人性侵他的妻子。尽管听起来很荒谬，但詹妮弗和达伦似乎真的感到恐惧，而且袭击似乎已经发生了。达伦后来写信给詹妮弗：“我陪你度过了这一切。你做得很好。他真的以为他击垮了你，并把我赶走了。我们打败了他。”达伦建议他们加快五年计划，这样詹妮弗就能更快地离开杰米。与此同时，两人想出了一个计划，用代码“575”开始他们的短信。这样，达伦就会知道他在和詹妮弗说话，而不是杰米。根据这些信息，调查人员推断杰米一直在
contacting Darren through his wife's cell phone, which explained why there was no phone data linking Jamie to Darren. While investigators still couldn't figure out exactly what was going on, the situation seemed serious. From the bits and pieces they could piece together, it seemed like Jamie was subjecting Jennifer to abuse. Darren reminded her to keep up the fight, saying that he loved her and would never lose her. Days later, Darren received an email from Jamie Faith with the subject line, received an email from Jamie Faith with the subject line, Please Stay Away. It read in part, Darren, I got your email from Jennifer's phone. I would normally call you to discuss this, but I don't want this to be an angry conversation, so it's easier for me to send you an email and
通过他妻子的手机联系达伦，这就解释了为什么没有电话数据将杰米与达伦联系起来。虽然调查人员仍然无法弄清楚到底发生了什么，但情况似乎很严重。从他们拼凑出的零碎信息来看，杰米似乎在对詹妮弗进行虐待。达伦提醒她要坚持战斗，说他爱她，永远不会失去她。几天后，达伦收到了杰米·费思的一封邮件，主题行是“请远离”。部分内容写道：“达伦，我从詹妮弗的手机上看到了你的邮件。我通常会打电话给你讨论这个问题，但我不想让这成为一场愤怒的谈话，所以发邮件对我来说更容易，并且
hope we can settle this in a civil manner. I want to make a plea to you, man to man, to please leave my family alone. I know you and Jennifer have a strong history together, but the fact is you haven't been around. I have. You have no right to come waltzing back into her life and destroy everything she and I have built together. If someone had done that to your family, you would not have stood for it." Darren responded that same day, alluding to the terrible things that Jamie had done to Jennifer. Everything you did to her this past week she went along with to make you happy," he wrote. I am at a loss to see how a man that says he loves her and needs her in his life could treat her like that. I saw how bad she is hurting and I am very concerned for her safety there.
希望我们能以文明的方式解决这个问题。我想以男人的身份恳求你，请离开我的家人。我知道你和詹妮弗有一段深厚的历史，但事实是你一直不在。而我在。你没有权利闯回她的生活，摧毁她和我共同建立的一切。如果有人对你的家人这样做，你也不会容忍的。”达伦当天回复，提到了杰米对詹妮弗所做的可怕事情。“你过去一周对她所做的一切，她都顺从了，只是为了让你开心，”他写道，“我无法理解一个声称爱她、需要她在生命中的男人怎么能那样对待她。我看到了她受了多大的伤害，我非常担心她在那里的人身安全。”
I have been talking with her at night because she is terrified of you. I will for sure keep checking in on her until I feel you have regained some sense and can control yourself around Jennifer. Do you actually see how you are making her feel? You alone are destroying what you have there. Be the husband you say you want to be. Respect her. Let her feel safe around you and being home with you. Jamie's curt response arrived the next day.
“我晚上一直在和她说话，因为她很怕你。我一定会继续关注她，直到我觉得你恢复了一些理智，并且能在詹妮弗身边控制住自己。你真的看到你让她感觉如何了吗？你一个人正在摧毁你们在那里拥有的一切。做一个你说你想成为的丈夫。尊重她。让她在你身边感到安全，让她在家里和你在一起感到安全。”杰米简短的回复在第二天到达。
First off, don't insult me. You're more than friends. Second, you didn't address any of my concerns. Third, her safety is my responsibility, not yours. I'm done communicating with you. My priority now is to make sure Jennifer knows where she belongs and who she belongs to. And you can check in with her all you want. She'll learn what to tell you and what not to." what to tell you and what not to. In early May, Darren received another email from Jamie that read, Has Jennifer been telling you everything like she is supposed to? I have a feeling she has stopped talking to you about what's been going on. I am finally going to get what I want from her this weekend. Make sure you ask her about it. Look up any rough gangbang triple penetration with breath control porn and that's what we'll be doing to her. See if she will tell you. If she doesn't, I'll need to start sending details again."
“首先，别侮辱我。你们不仅仅是朋友。第二，你没有解决我的任何担忧。第三，她的安全是我的责任，不是你的。我不再和你沟通了。我现在的工作重点是确保詹妮弗知道她属于哪里，属于谁。你可以随心所欲地关注她。她会学会什么该告诉你，什么不该告诉你。”5月初，达伦收到了杰米发来的另一封邮件，上面写着：“詹妮弗有没有像她应该做的那样告诉你一切？我有种感觉，她已经不再和你谈论正在发生的事情了。我终于要在周末从她那里得到我想要的了。一定要问问她。去查查任何粗暴的轮奸、三重进入和呼吸控制色情片，这就是我们将要对她做的。看看她会不会告诉你。如果她不告诉，我需要开始再次发送细节。”
Later that month, Darren received another email from Jamie with the subject line, injuries old and new. Attached were seven close-up images of what appeared to be injuries to Jennifer's body, including severe bruises, a bleeding lip, and most chillingly a healed neck wound. The accompanying message read, Good stuff. Enjoy knowing you can't do a fucking thing about it. Days later, Jamie sent Darren an email describing in disturbing detail how he and his friends were violently raping Jennifer. He called it training and told Darren, "'Too bad you will never know that sweet tone of her begging me to let her go.'" Darren responded, "'Jamie, you are fucked. You are sitting there thinking I can do nothing to stop you from abusing Jennifer, and I am going to show you I have plenty to ruin and to destroy your life."
那个月晚些时候，达伦收到了杰米发来的另一封邮件，主题行是“新旧伤痕”。附件是七张特写图片，看起来是詹妮弗身体上的伤痕，包括严重的淤青、流血的嘴唇，最令人不寒而栗的是一个已经愈合的颈部伤口。随附的信息写道：“好东西。享受知道你对此无能为力的感觉吧。”几天后，杰米给达伦发了一封邮件，以令人不安的细节描述了他和他的朋友们是如何暴力强奸詹妮弗的。他称之为“训练”，并告诉达伦：“‘可惜你永远不会知道她求我放过她时那种甜美的语调。’”达伦回复道：“‘杰米，你完了。你坐在那里以为我无法阻止你虐待詹妮弗，我会让你看到我有足够多的东西来毁掉你的生活。’”
Darren threatened to take all the evidence of Jamie's abuse to the police and to Jamie's employer unless he promised to stop abusing Jennifer. There's still hope for you, Darren wrote. For some reason, Jennifer still believes you have redeeming qualities, so I'm giving you a last chance. You will never take Jennifer away from the house to be used and raped by other men. All the fucked up sexual things you were doing to Jennifer will stop." Knowing that Texas had a 10-year statute of limitations for rape, Darren told Jamie he intended to keep all the evidence of his crimes for the
达伦威胁说，除非杰米承诺停止虐待詹妮弗，否则他将把所有关于杰米虐待的证据交给警方和杰米的雇主。“你还有希望，”达伦写道，“出于某种原因，詹妮弗仍然相信你有可取之处，所以我给你最后一次机会。你永远不会再把詹妮弗带离家去被其他男人使用和强奸。所有你对詹妮弗做的那些变态的性行为都必须停止。”知道德克萨斯州对强奸有10年的诉讼时效，达伦告诉杰米，他打算保留所有犯罪证据
next decade. "'I am a man of my word,' Darren warned. "'If you fail in any aspect, I will destroy your life." Darren then emailed Jennifer, assuring her that he wouldn't go to the authorities without her consent, but pleaded with her to at least leave her husband. Jennifer didn't follow Darren's advice, nor did Jamie heed his warning. Jamie began sending Darren close-up graphic images of Jennifer's sexual abuse taking place. Darren begged Jennifer to tell the police, but she refused, saying that Jamie would punish her for speaking out. She also feared that her daughter could face retribution and didn't want her to know the truth about Jamie's evil nature. Feeling helpless in Tennessee, Darren asked Jennifer to confide in a friend close by who
在接下来的十年里。“‘我是一个信守诺言的人，’达伦警告说，‘如果你在任何方面失败，我都会毁了你的生活。’”达伦随后给詹妮弗发了邮件，向她保证他不会在未经她同意的情况下向当局举报，但他恳求她至少离开她的丈夫。詹妮弗没有听从达伦的建议，杰米也没有理会他的警告。杰米开始给达伦发送詹妮弗遭受性虐待的特写图片。达伦恳求詹妮弗告诉警察，但她拒绝了，说杰米会因为她告发而惩罚她。她还担心她的女儿可能会面临报复，不想让她知道杰米邪恶本性的真相。在田纳西州感到无助的达伦，请求詹妮弗向附近的一位朋友吐露心声，
could help her in person. She reluctantly gave Darren the email address of a coworker named Rob Schmidt. Jennifer explained that she had known Rob for over 15 years. She playfully referred to him as her work husband and viewed him as a confidant. Darren emailed Rob, introducing himself and saying, hitches. I am asking if you are willing to get involved and help Jennifer get out of this situation." Rob replied in shock. He had known Jamie for a long time and didn't think he was capable of such abuse. He probed Darren for more details. Darren explained that it all began shortly after he reconnected with the Jennifer. For the first attack, Jennifer was gang raped by Jamie and six other men. The rapes continued almost every weekend after
可以亲自帮助她。她不情愿地给了达伦一位名叫罗伯·施密特（Rob Schmidt）的同事的电子邮件地址。詹妮弗解释说她认识罗伯已经超过15年了。她戏称他为她的“工作丈夫”，并将他视为知己。达伦给罗伯发了邮件，介绍了自己并说：“……我请求你是否愿意参与并帮助詹妮弗摆脱这种困境。”罗伯震惊地回复了。他认识杰米很久了，认为他不可能做出这种虐待行为。他向达伦询问更多细节。达伦解释说，这一切都始于他与詹妮弗重新联系后不久。第一次袭击中，詹妮弗被杰米和其他六名男子轮奸。此后几乎每个周末强奸都在继续，
that, with one carried out on Jamie's birthday involving at least 10 men. Jennifer had to take a whole week off work to recover. She had since developed a urinary tract infection, but Jamie's relentless assaults prevented her from treating it and she was chronically ill as a result. Darren informed Rob that a long-time friend of Jamie's named Jeremy Gabler was almost always involved in the attacks. If Jennifer ever refused to comply, Jamie used a stun gun on her. Darren believed that Jamie was trying to make it so that no other man would ever want Jennifer. He felt like Jamie was hurting Jennifer in order to hurt him too. Rob was shocked to learn that Jennifer hadn't gone to the authorities,
其中一次发生在杰米的生日那天，涉及至少10名男子。詹妮弗不得不请了一整周的假来恢复。她后来患上了尿路感染，但杰米无情的袭击阻止了她进行治疗，结果她长期患病。达伦告诉罗伯，杰米的一位老朋友杰里米·盖布勒（Jeremy Gabler）几乎总是参与袭击。如果詹妮弗拒绝配合，杰米就会对她使用电击枪。达伦认为杰米是想让詹妮弗再也不想被任何其他男人染指。他觉得杰米伤害詹妮弗也是为了伤害他。罗伯得知詹妮弗没有向当局举报感到震惊，
but he acknowledged that she had a strong sense of loyalty, saying, "...my guess is she wants to spare Jamie and is probably blaming herself for this to an extent." Darren hoped that with Rob's help, Jennifer would realise she had more people on her side and would gain the confidence to stand up for herself and speak out. If not, Darren at least felt reassured that he wasn't the only one who knew about the abuse and Rob could take immediate action if things got worse. Shortly after, Rob emailed Darren claiming he had called Jamie to confront him. Jamie denied everything and accused Jennifer of making it all up. Rob wrote,
但他承认她有很强的忠诚感，说：“……我猜她想放过杰米，并且在某种程度上可能在责怪自己。”达伦希望在罗伯的帮助下，詹妮弗能意识到她身边有更多的人支持她，并获得自信来为自己挺身而出并说出真相。如果没有，达伦至少感到欣慰的是，他不是唯一一个知道虐待事件的人，如果情况恶化，罗伯可以立即采取行动。不久之后，罗伯给达伦发邮件，声称他已经打电话给杰米与他对质。杰米否认了一切，并指责詹妮弗编造了这一切。罗伯写道：
kill the guy. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. If you're a renter, do you ever feel like you're stuck in a loop of rent payments just watching your money vanish into thin air? What if you could turn that around and start earning some serious rewards? That's where built rewards come in. Built is breaking ground as a neighbourhood rewards program that hooks you up with points on your rent. Every month, pay your rent and watch the built points roll in. Use points to jet off on a dream vacation. Put them toward a flight or hotel stay with 500 plus airlines and more than 700,000 hotels and properties. You can also use your points to book fitness studio classes or redeem them toward a future
“杀了那个家伙。”Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。如果您是租房者，您是否有时觉得陷入了租金支付的循环中，看着您的钱凭空消失？如果能扭转局面并开始赚取一些丰厚的奖励呢？这就是Built Rewards的用武之地。Built作为一种邻里奖励计划正在开辟新天地，它为您提供租金积分。每个月，支付租金并看着Built积分滚滚而来。使用积分去梦想度假。将它们用于500多家航空公司和超过700,000家酒店及物业的航班或酒店住宿。您还可以使用积分预订健身房课程或将它们兑换为未来的
rent payment. They're designed to meet your lifestyle. Pay rent hassle-free through the Build Rewards app. Your rank game just got a major upgrade. Built points have been consistently ranked the highest value point currency by the points guy and bank rate. Earn points by paying rent right now when you go to joinbuilt.com slash case file. That's J O I N B I L T dot com slash case file. Make sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. Joinbuilt.com slash case file to start earning points with your rent payments today. I love a good deal as much as the next person, but I don't want to have to jump through hoops
租金支付。它们旨在满足您的生活方式。通过Built Rewards应用程序轻松支付租金。您的租房游戏刚刚得到了重大升级。Built积分一直被The Points Guy和Bankrate评为最高价值的积分货币。现在前往joinbuilt.com/casefile，通过支付租金赚取积分。即J O I N B I L T点com斜杠casefile。请务必使用我们的网址，以便他们知道是我们推荐的。立即访问Joinbuilt.com/casefile，开始通过租金支付赚取积分。我和其他人一样喜欢划算的交易，但我不想为了省几块钱而跳过障碍
or crawl through hot coals just to save a few bucks. It has to be easy. No hoops, no BS. So when Mint Mobile said it was easy to get wireless for $15 a month with the purchase of a three-month plan, I called them on it. Turns out, it really is that easy to get wireless for $15 a month. The longest part of the process will be the time you spend on hold waiting to break up with your old provider. To get started, head over to mintmobile.com slash case file. There, you'll see that right now you can get any three month plan, including the unlimited plan, for just $15 a month. All plans come with high-speed data, unlimited talk and text, and they're delivered on the nation's largest 5G network.
或爬过热煤。它必须简单。没有障碍，没有废话。所以当Mint Mobile说购买三个月的计划，每月15美元就能获得无线服务时，我向他们求证了。事实证明，每月15美元获得无线服务确实就是这么简单。整个过程中最长的部分将是你等待与旧服务提供商分手的通话时间。要开始，请前往mintmobile.com/casefile。在那里，你会看到现在你可以以每月仅15美元的价格获得任何三个月的计划，包括无限计划。所有计划都附带高速数据、无限通话和短信，并且在全国最大的5G网络上提供。
Plus, you can keep your own phone and bring your existing number and contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3 month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to mintmobile.com slash case file. month at mintmobile.com slash case file. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 per month. New customers on first 3 month plan only. Speed slower above 40GB on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content.
此外，您可以保留自己的手机并携带现有的号码和联系人。要获得此新客户优惠并以每月仅15美元的价格获得新的3个月高级无线计划，请访问mintmobile.com/casefile。每月在mintmobile.com/casefile。需要预付45美元，相当于每月15美元。仅限首次购买3个月计划的新客户。无限计划超过40GB后速度变慢。适用额外的税费和限制。详情请参阅Mint Mobile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。
content. Rob Schmidt and Darren Lopez remained in contact as they discussed how they could best help Jennifer. Rob shared Darren's fury at the whole situation and the pair vented their brewing anger to one another. At one point, Rob forwarded a photo Jennifer had sent him of burnt flesh and warned Darren, "'Jamie's been burning her, among other things. She didn't want me to tell you, so please keep it between us.'" Darren later confided in Rob, "'I still feel Jamie's very fucked up in the head. I know I won't feel better about our situation
内容。罗伯·施密特和达伦·洛佩兹保持联系，讨论他们如何能最好地帮助詹妮弗。罗伯分享了达伦对整个局势的愤怒，两人向对方发泄了他们酝酿已久的怒火。有一次，罗伯转发了詹妮弗发给他的一张烧焦皮肤的照片，并警告达伦：“‘杰米一直在烧她，还有其他事情。她不想让我告诉你，所以请保密。’”达伦后来向罗伯吐露：“‘我仍然觉得杰米的脑子坏透了。我知道我不会对我们的处境感到好转
until Jennifer is out of that house away from him, or she lets me put a bullet in Jamie's head." Rob replied, "...if it were up to me, I would tell you to go for it. I'll give you an alibi." Darren continued to receive confronting emails from both Jennifer and Jamie on a daily basis. They both described in detail the pain and torment Jennifer faced, but while Jennifer's emails were anguished and frightened, Jamie's were mocking, as if he was goading Darren. After one particularly terrifying attack, Jennifer turned to Darren for support. She said that Jamie had held her head underwater in their hot tub while forcing her to perform oral sex on him. She lost consciousness and came to with the Jamie performing CPR on her. Darren implored Jennifer to go to the police, but she continued to refuse, fearful of what Jamie would do to both her and her daughter if she exposed his crimes.
直到詹妮弗离开那个房子远离他，或者她让我给杰米的脑袋一颗子弹。’”罗伯回复道：“……如果由我决定，我会告诉你去做。我会为你提供不在场证明。”达伦继续每天收到来自詹妮弗和杰米的令人震惊的邮件。他们都详细描述了詹妮弗所面临的痛苦和折磨，但詹妮弗的邮件充满了痛苦和恐惧，而杰米的邮件则是嘲讽的，仿佛他在挑衅达伦。在一次特别可怕的袭击后，詹妮弗向达伦寻求支持。她说杰米把她的头按在热水浴缸的水下，同时强迫她为他进行口交。她失去了知觉，醒来时发现杰米正在对她进行心肺复苏。达伦恳求詹妮弗报警，但她继续拒绝，害怕如果她揭露他的罪行，杰米会对她和她的女儿做什么。
As October 2020 approached, Jamie emailed Darren saying he was planning something special for his and Jennifer's upcoming 15-year anniversary. He said he enjoyed the near-fatal hot tub incident so much that he was going to see how many men Jennifer could handle in the hot tub. He already had seven guys lined up for the assault. up for the assault. While investigators had initially theorised that Darren had been hired to kill Jamie, this email changed their minds. They now believed Darren had been motivated by a desire to protect Jennifer. Given that Jamie Faith was killed on Friday October 9, 2020, the day before the hot tub assault was set to take place, investigators believed that Jamie's threat of the attack was the catalyst that finally prompted Darren to act. After all, he was specially trained to save vulnerable people under the imposing threat of death and had earned accolades for his heroism. The level of overkill as well as the bullet to Jamie's groin made sense given the context of his sexual abuse. It appeared that Darren Lopez wasn't a cold-blooded killer after all,
随着2020年10月的临近，杰米给达伦发邮件说，他正在为他和詹妮弗即将到来的15周年纪念日计划一些特别的事情。他说他非常享受那次差点致命的热水浴缸事件，所以他要看看詹妮弗在热水浴缸里能应付多少男人。他已经安排了七个人进行袭击。虽然调查人员最初推测达伦是被雇来杀杰米的，但这封邮件改变了他们的想法。他们现在认为达伦是出于保护詹妮弗的愿望。鉴于杰米·费思于2020年10月9日星期五被杀，即热水浴缸袭击发生的前一天，调查人员认为杰米的袭击威胁是最终促使达伦采取行动的催化剂。毕竟，他受过专门训练，可以在死亡威胁下拯救弱势群体，并因其英雄主义而获得嘉奖。考虑到性虐待的背景，这种过度的暴力以及射向杰米腹股沟的子弹是有道理的。看来达伦·洛佩兹毕竟不是一个冷血杀手，
but a desperate man driven to save a woman he loved. man driven to save a woman he loved. What investigators couldn't quite get their heads around was that Jamie Faith's sadistic, cruel and violent behaviour was in complete contrast to the kind and gentle man his loved ones had described him to be. They wondered if everything everyone knew about Jamie Faith was completely wrong. Investigators tracked down Jeremy Gebler, the long-time friend of Jamie's who Jennifer had implicated in her numerous sexual assaults. Jeremy appeared to be shocked by the allegations levelled against him. He vehemently denied ever assaulting Jennifer, claiming he'd only ever had positive interactions with her. In fact, he was partially responsible for having set her and Jamie up in the first place, believing they were both good people who were perfect for one another.
而是一个为了拯救他所爱的女人而被逼无奈的男人。调查人员无法理解的是，杰米·费思那种虐待狂、残忍和暴力的行为，与他亲人所描述的那种善良温柔的男人完全相反。他们想知道每个人所了解的关于杰米·费思的一切是否完全错误。调查人员追踪到了杰里米·盖布勒，他是杰米的老朋友，詹妮弗在她的多次性侵指控中牵连了他。杰里米似乎对针对他的指控感到震惊。他强烈否认曾经侵犯过詹妮弗，声称他与她只有过积极的互动。事实上，他还在一定程度上促成了她和杰米的结合，认为他们都是彼此完美的善良人。
Jeremy maintained that Jamie had been a courteous and compassionate man. In the many years they'd known each other, Jeremy had never once sensed anything sinister was going on behind the scenes of the faith marriage. Investigators looked into Jeremy's whereabouts over the weekends in mid-2020 where the sexual abuse of Jennifer was alleged to have taken place. Jeremy lived over 800 miles away in the state of Arizona and was ruled out of having collaborated in Jamie's alleged crimes. Jeremy was also one of the select few people who Jennifer had added to her group text message thread wherein she provided updates about Jamie's case. Why would she do this if Jeremy was one of her feared abusers? Jennifer had also added her close co-worker,
杰里米坚持认为杰米一直是一个彬彬有礼且富有同情心的人。在他们相识的多年里，杰里米从未感觉到费思婚姻背后有什么阴险的事情发生。调查人员调查了杰里米在2020年中期周末的行踪，当时詹妮弗被指控遭受了性虐待。杰里米住在800多英里外的亚利桑那州，被排除了参与杰米所谓罪行的可能。杰里米也是詹妮弗添加到她的群组短信线程中的少数几个人之一，她在那里提供关于杰米案件的最新消息。如果杰里米是她害怕的施暴者之一，她为什么要这样做？詹妮弗还添加了她亲密的同事，
Rob Schmidt, to the group text. When Rob was shown the emails sent between him and Darren, he was stunned. According to Rob, he hadn't written the emails and had never even heard of Darren Lopez. Inquiries were made with the email service provider. They revealed that the email account attributed to Rob Schmidt had been created on the same day that Darren first began receiving messages from that address. The same thing went for the email account attributed to Jamie Faith. Both accounts were deleted at the same time on the same day, shortly before Jamie was murdered. When Jennifer Faith had been charged with obstruction of justice following Darren's arrest, investigators carried out a search warrant on her home and serendipitously took possession of her
罗伯·施密特，到群组短信中。当罗伯看到他和达伦之间发送的邮件时，他惊呆了。据罗伯说，他并没有写过这些邮件，甚至从未听说过达伦·洛佩兹。调查人员向电子邮件服务提供商进行了查询。他们发现，归属于罗伯·施密特的电子邮件账户是在达伦第一次开始收到来自该地址的消息的同一天创建的。归属于杰米·费思的电子邮件账户也是如此。两个账户都在同一天的同一时间被删除，就在杰米被谋杀前不久。当詹妮弗·费思在达伦被捕后被控妨碍司法公正时，调查人员对她的家执行了搜查令，并偶然获得了她的
computer. An examination of Jennifer's inbox revealed a cache of emails sent between herself and Darren in which they discussed the abuse inflicted by Jamie. Investigators also found images of the injuries that had been sent to Daren as proof of Jamie's violence. Some of the images were indeed of Jennifer, but they were found to have been taken eight years earlier and were the result of a car wreck. Others, like the bloodied lip, were stock images Jennifer had downloaded from the internet. The images allegedly depicting Jennifer's sexual abuse were also found to be stills from pornographic movies. Jennifer's computer was sent to the Federal Bureau of Investigation to be more thoroughly examined. They uncovered a deception so unbelievable that case detectives had only had one word for it.
电脑。对詹妮弗收件箱的检查揭示了一系列她与达伦之间发送的邮件，他们在邮件中讨论了杰米施加的虐待。调查人员还发现了发送给达伦作为杰米暴力证据的伤痕图片。其中一些图片确实是詹妮弗的，但被发现是八年前拍摄的，是一场车祸的结果。其他的，比如流血的嘴唇，是詹妮弗从网上下载的库存图片。那些据称描绘詹妮弗性虐待的图片也被发现是色情电影的剧照。詹妮弗的电脑被送往联邦调查局进行更彻底的检查。他们揭露了一个令人难以置信的骗局，案件侦探对此只有一个词来形容。
Diabolical. It turned out that Jennifer was the sole mastermind behind every single email that had been sent to Darren, including those allegedly sent from Rob Schmidt and Jamie Faith. There was zero evidence to suggest that Darren and Jamie had ever been in genuine contact. Any time Darren believed he was communicating with Jamie via text or email, he was in fact speaking with Jennifer. This level of deceit required an exceptional amount of time and effort. Jennifer was sending multiple emails to Darren each day from the fake accounts while also pretending to be her own husband and maintaining round-the-clock communication with Darren as herself. Investigators had never seen anything like it. They also found no evidence that Jamie had ever been abusive to his wife. All the stories of physical, emotional, and sexual abuse were deemed to have been outright lies manufactured by Jennifer. And as it turned
太恶毒了。事实证明，詹妮弗是发给达伦的每一封电子邮件的幕后主使，包括那些据称来自罗布·施密特和杰米·费斯的邮件。没有任何证据表明达伦和杰米之间有过真正的接触。每当达伦以为自己通过短信或电子邮件与杰米交流时，他实际上是在与詹妮弗对话。这种程度的欺骗需要投入极大的时间和精力。詹妮弗每天用虚假账户给达伦发送多封电子邮件，同时还要假扮成自己的丈夫，并以自己的身份与达伦保持全天候的联系。调查人员从未见过这样的事情。他们也没有发现任何证据表明杰米曾虐待过他的妻子。所有关于身体、情感和性虐待的故事都被认定是詹妮弗捏造的彻头彻尾的谎言。而且事实证明，
out, this wasn't the first time she'd done such a thing. Investigators discovered that Jennifer had a history of contacting ex-partners and telling them she was abused by a husband or boyfriend in order to provoke a reaction. Jennifer's second husband Rick told Dateline that he and Jennifer had originally started dating while she was separated from her first husband. One day, Jennifer confided in Rick that her marriage had been hellish. She called her husband a monster, saying he had physically, emotionally and sexually abused her. According to Jennifer, her husband sometimes tortured her with implements and brought his friends over to gang rape her. Rick was shocked and encouraged Jennifer to go to the police, but she refused.
这已经不是她第一次做这种事了。调查人员发现，詹妮弗有联系前任伴侣并告诉他们自己被丈夫或男友虐待以激起对方反应的前科。詹妮弗的第二任丈夫里克告诉《日界线》节目，他和詹妮弗最初是在她与第一任丈夫分居期间开始约会的。有一天，詹妮弗向里克吐露，她的婚姻简直是地狱。她称丈夫为恶魔，说他对自己进行了身体、情感和性虐待。据詹妮弗说，她丈夫有时会用工具折磨她，并带朋友回来轮奸她。里克感到震惊，并鼓励詹妮弗报警，但她拒绝了。
Jennifer told Rick she wished her husband was dead. As Jennifer continued to offload stories of her horrific abuse, Rick found himself wanting to kill Jennifer's husband. He explained to Dateline, "...it's her idea until she makes you think that it's your idea. The pair devised a plan for Rick to shoot Jennifer's husband while he was out tending to his garden. But Jennifer had a last-minute change of heart, saying she didn't want her daughter's father dead. She ultimately divorced her first husband and married Rick instead. first husband and married Rick instead. Shortly after their wedding, Rick started receiving emails from two men he didn't know. One claimed to be a surgeon and the other an airline pilot. They both told Rick that Jennifer was hot and said he didn't appreciate her enough. Rick ended up divorcing Jennifer within nine months,
詹妮弗告诉里克，她希望她丈夫死。随着詹妮弗不断倾诉她遭受的可怕虐待，里克发现自己也想杀了詹妮弗的丈夫。他向《日界线》解释道：“……这最初是她的想法，直到她让你觉得这是你自己的想法。”两人制定了一个计划，让里克在詹妮弗的丈夫去花园打理花草时开枪射杀他。但詹妮弗在最后一刻改变了主意，说她不想让她女儿的父亲死。她最终与第一任丈夫离婚，转而嫁给了里克。婚礼后不久，里克开始收到两名陌生男子的电子邮件。一人自称是外科医生，另一人是航空公司飞行员。他们都告诉里克，詹妮弗很性感，并说他不够珍惜她。里克最终在九个月内与詹妮弗离婚，
and in hindsight he was certain she was behind the strange emails. After learning what happened to Jamie Faith, Rick assumed the stories about Jennifer's first husband were entirely false. He described to Jennifer as the most evil person he'd ever come into contact with, saying that being with her was like, swimming in a sea of lies, manipulation and pain. Investigators speculated that Jennifer stopped Rick from killing her first husband because she didn't feel confident in his abilities. In contrast, Darren Lopez was a trained killer who could get the job done swiftly and discreetly without drawing any attention towards Jennifer. There was also another element that made Darren the ideal hitman. In one of his initial emails to Jennifer, Darren had written extensively
事后回想起来，他确信那些奇怪的邮件都是她搞的鬼。在得知杰米·费斯的遭遇后，里克认为关于詹妮弗第一任丈夫的故事完全是虚构的。他形容詹妮弗是他接触过的最邪恶的人，说和她在一起就像是“在谎言、操纵和痛苦的海洋中游泳”。调查人员推测，詹妮弗阻止里克杀害她的第一任丈夫，是因为她对他的能力没有信心。相比之下，达伦·洛佩兹是一名训练有素的杀手，能够迅速且隐秘地完成任务，而不会引起对詹妮弗的任何怀疑。还有另一个因素使达伦成为理想的杀手。在给詹妮弗的最初几封邮件中，达伦曾详细写道
about his experiences in the military. Specifically, the Humvee explosion in Iraq that left him with a traumatic brain injury and post-traumatic stress disorder. This information immediately piqued Jennifer's interest. Through her work as a therapist, Jennifer told Darren that she had treated many patients with traumatic brain injuries over the years, many of whom were soldiers. She claimed to be a certified brain injury specialist who had written a number of articles for the Brain Injury Alliance of Arizona. Jennifer said she wanted to help Darren and convinced him to send her a copy of his medical records from the Department of Defense and to the Department of Veteran Affairs. Over 912 pages, the reports disclosed that Darren also had a major depressive disorder, as well as attention deficit hyperactivity
他在军队中的经历。具体来说，是伊拉克的一场悍马爆炸事件，导致他患上了创伤性脑损伤和创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。这些信息立即引起了詹妮弗的兴趣。通过她作为治疗师的工作，詹妮弗告诉达伦，多年来她治疗过许多患有创伤性脑损伤的病人，其中许多是军人。她声称自己是一名认证的脑损伤专家，曾为亚利桑那州脑损伤联盟撰写过许多文章。詹妮弗说她想帮助达伦，并说服他将国防部和退伍军人事务部的医疗记录副本发给她。这些报告长达912页，披露了达伦还患有重度抑郁症以及注意力缺陷多动
disorder. He also suffered from severe migraines, vision loss, ringing in his ears, dizziness, vertigo, nightmares, sleeping difficulties, and frightening flashbacks of combat. He was on various medications to treat these conditions, while neurological tests showed that he had performed below average on cognitive, attention, and memory function. His PTSD could be triggered by stress or crowds, which then caused him to spiral emotionally. With the Jennifer's knowledge of traumatic brain injuries, she was aware of the many challenges that patients faced. There were personality changes, behavioural issues,
障碍。他还患有严重的偏头痛、视力丧失、耳鸣、头晕、眩晕、噩梦、睡眠困难以及可怕的战斗闪回。他服用各种药物来治疗这些疾病，而神经学测试显示他在认知、注意力和记忆功能方面的表现低于平均水平。他的PTSD可能会因压力或人群而触发，进而导致他情绪失控。凭借詹妮弗对创伤性脑损伤的了解，她很清楚患者面临的许多挑战。包括性格改变、行为问题、
memory lapses, difficulties processing profound emotions and difficulties with decision making. Post-traumatic stress disorder can also alter the way a person's brain works, specifically the emotional core of the brain. Veterans with PTSD often endure irritability, hyper arousal and aggression problems as they find it difficult to turn their brain off and relax. Some feel like they are always on edge, enduring ongoing feelings of fear, horror, anger, guilt and shame. They can also struggle to trust others as they typically view the world through a negative lens. When their trauma is triggered, they often depersonalise and disassociate. These skills serve them well while surviving on the battlefield, but have devastating impacts in civilian life.
记忆缺失、处理深层情绪的困难以及决策困难。创伤后应激障碍也会改变一个人的大脑运作方式，特别是大脑的情绪核心。患有PTSD的退伍军人经常忍受易怒、过度觉醒和攻击性问题，因为他们发现很难让大脑停下来放松。有些人觉得他们总是处于紧张状态，忍受着持续的恐惧、惊恐、愤怒、内疚和羞耻感。他们也可能难以信任他人，因为他们通常通过负面视角看待世界。当他们的创伤被触发时，他们经常会产生人格解体和解离。这些技能在战场上生存时很有用，但在平民生活中却会产生毁灭性的影响。
From Darren Lopez's medical records, it was clear he was a particularly vulnerable individual. He had been deemed fully disabled and was considered unfit to perform normally in society. As soon as Jennifer learnt of Darren's condition, she leaned heavily into the affection he displayed towards her. Investigators believed she used these emotions to manipulate and exploit Darren, telling lie after lie about the horrific, fictitious abuse her husband was allegedly inflicting. The stories Jennifer concocted were described by investigators as, some of the most sadistic things you can possibly dream up. It appeared that Jennifer had successfully tricked a disabled veteran into becoming her
从达伦·洛佩兹的医疗记录来看，很明显他是一个特别脆弱的人。他被认定完全丧失劳动能力，被认为不适合在社会中正常生活。一旦詹妮弗得知达伦的情况，她就极力利用他对自己表现出的爱慕之情。调查人员认为，她利用这些情绪来操纵和剥削达伦，谎话连篇地讲述她丈夫据称对她施加的可怕的、虚构的虐待。詹妮弗编造的故事被调查人员描述为“你能想象到的最残忍的事情”。看来詹妮弗已经成功地诱骗了一名残疾退伍军人成为她
own personal assassin. All the while while she was living a double life, maintaining her seemingly happy marriage with Jamie. In contrast to Jennifer's stories, it appeared Jamie had no idea she was engaging in an emotional affair. While all this was going on, he remained at home with Jennifer and even took her on two trips interstate to visit his family. It was now clear that Jennifer's efforts to thwart her husband's murder investigation weren't to protect Darren, her daughter, or even Jamie. She was only ever protecting herself. The question was, why did Jennifer want Jamie dead?
自己的私人刺客。与此同时，她过着双重生活，维持着她与杰米看似幸福的婚姻。与詹妮弗的故事相反，杰米似乎根本不知道她正在进行一场精神出轨。在这一切发生的同时，他留在家里陪伴詹妮弗，甚至带她进行了两次州际旅行去探望他的家人。现在很清楚，詹妮弗阻挠丈夫谋杀案调查的努力并不是为了保护达伦、她的女儿，甚至也不是为了保护杰米。她一直以来都只是在保护自己。问题是，为什么詹妮弗想让杰米死？
By all accounts, he had been a loving and supportive husband and father who provided Jennifer and her daughter with financial security and a happy home life. Investigators wondered whether Jennifer thought the grass would be greener with Darren. Perhaps she envisioned the two of them having a more exciting and attractive life. Or maybe it was all about money. Jamie had over a million dollars in life insurance and retirement funds, which Jennifer was the beneficiary of. Having access to this money also meant she could use Darren's financial diastrates to her own advantage. In the words of one US attorney, Jennifer Faith preyed on Darren Lopez's pocketbook to propel him to murder.
据各方说法，他一直是一位充满爱心和支持的丈夫和父亲，为詹妮弗和她的女儿提供了经济保障和幸福的家庭生活。调查人员想知道詹妮弗是否认为和达伦在一起会更好。也许她设想他们两人会过上更令人兴奋和更有吸引力的生活。又或者这一切都是为了钱。杰米有超过一百万美元的人寿保险和退休基金，詹妮弗是受益人。拥有这些钱也意味着她可以利用达伦的经济困境为自己谋利。用一位美国检察官的话说，詹妮弗·费斯利用达伦·洛佩兹的钱包来推动他去杀人。
Criminal prosecutors hoped they could get Darren Lopez to cooperate with them once he learned the truth about Jennifer. However, when shown evidence of her extensive con, Darren had the opposite reaction. He flat out refused to believe the allegations against Jennifer and remained convinced that Jamie Faith was an abuser. Darren didn't trust anyone but Jennifer and simply couldn't come to terms with the possibility that the whole ordeal had been a scam. Even his own court-appointed attorney struggled to get him to accept the truth of the matter. Darren stood by Jennifer even when the extent of her deception was publicly exposed. She had done well to muddy the waters by sending Darren a letter beforehand.
刑事检察官希望在达伦·洛佩兹得知关于詹妮弗的真相后，能让他与他们合作。然而，当向他展示詹妮弗大规模欺诈的证据时，达伦的反应却截然相反。他断然拒绝相信针对詹妮弗的指控，并坚信杰米·费斯是一个虐待者。达伦除了詹妮弗谁也不信，根本无法接受整个事件可能是一场骗局的可能性。即使是他自己的法庭指定律师也难以让他接受事实真相。即使在詹妮弗的欺骗程度被公开曝光后，达伦依然支持她。她事先给达伦写了一封信，成功地搅浑了水。
It began with the number 575, their secret code to confirm the letter was authentic. Jennifer wrote, Just a quick note to say I never lied to you and I never sent you the emails from any account but mine as me. You once said you would never believe anything about me unless you heard it from me. I hope that's still true. There is a ton more I wish I could say, but I can't right now. Soon, hopefully." For six months Darren refused to believe that Jennifer could have used him in such an abhorrent
信以数字575开头，这是他们确认信件真实性的秘密代码。詹妮弗写道：“只是简单写个便条告诉你，我从未对你撒谎，也从未用除我之外的任何账户以我的名义给你发过邮件。你曾经说过，除非亲耳听到我说，否则你永远不会相信关于我的任何事情。我希望现在依然如此。我还有很多话想说，但现在不能说。希望很快就能说。”六个月来，达伦拒绝相信詹妮弗会以如此令人厌恶的
way. He was convinced that the two were deeply in love and his hatred for Jamie was so pervasive and genuine, it was impossible for Darren to view him any other way. It took a difficult conversation with one of his daughters before Darren finally saw the light. With the veil lifted, he agreed to finally tell investigators the full story. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. According to Darren Lopez, he never wanted to be a homewrecker.
方式利用他。他坚信两人深爱着对方，他对杰米的仇恨是如此普遍和真实，以至于达伦不可能以任何其他方式看待他。直到与其中一个女儿进行了一次艰难的谈话，达伦才终于看清了真相。面纱揭开后，他终于同意向调查人员讲述完整的故事。《案件档案》很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供优质内容。据达伦·洛佩兹说，他从没想过要当破坏别人家庭的人。
When he confessed his feelings to Jennifer within days of them reconnecting, he assured her that he was willing to take things slow out of respect for her family. He didn't want Jennifer's daughter to think poorly of him or view him as the person responsible for breaking up their family. Furthermore, from what Jennifer had initially told Darren, he thought Jamie sounded like a legitimately good guy and hoped they could become friends. Darren encouraged Jennifer to be honest with the Jamie, even floating the idea that Jamie might agree to share Jennifer with him, so neither man wound up heartbroken.
当他在重新联系后的几天内向詹妮弗坦白自己的感情时，他向她保证，出于对她家庭的尊重，他愿意慢慢来。他不想让詹妮弗的女儿对他有不好的看法，或者把他视为破坏他们家庭的人。此外，从詹妮弗最初告诉达伦的情况来看，他觉得杰米听起来是个真正的好人，并希望他们能成为朋友。达伦鼓励詹妮弗对杰米诚实，甚至提出了杰米可能会同意与他分享詹妮弗的想法，这样两个男人都不会心碎。
It wasn't until Jennifer told Darren that she had come clean to Jamie about their emotional affair that Darren's opinion of Jamie began to change. Jennifer reported back that Jamie had taken the news poorly. He had become angry and violent, his abusive behaviour amplified by alcohol and cocaine. From then on, she constantly bombarded Darren with details about the horrific things Jamie subjected her to. She called Darren at all hours of the night, depriving him of sleep as she cried about the latest abuse she'd endured. In addition to the rapes, Jennifer claimed that Jamie kept her tied up in a closet, was restricting her diet, and had once forcibly cut her hair off. These details, coupled with the emails Darren received from Rob Schmerton to Jamie Faith, made him sick. He felt like he was losing his mind. While he wanted to alert the
直到詹妮弗告诉达伦她已经向杰米坦白了他们的精神出轨，达伦对杰米的看法才开始改变。詹妮弗反馈说，杰米对这个消息反应很糟糕。他变得愤怒和暴力，在酒精和可卡因的作用下，他的虐待行为变本加厉。从那时起，她不断地向达伦轰炸关于杰米对她施加的可怕细节。她在深夜随时给达伦打电话，让他无法入睡，哭诉她所遭受的最新虐待。除了强奸，詹妮弗还声称杰米把她绑在壁橱里，限制她的饮食，还曾强行剪掉她的头发。这些细节，加上达伦收到的来自罗布·施密特发给杰米·费斯的邮件，让他感到恶心。他觉得自己快要疯了。虽然他想通知
authorities, Jennifer made him swear not to. If Darren ever told the police, Jennifer said she would deny everything. Darren gave his word that he wouldn't go behind her back, and in the military, word that he wouldn't go behind her back, and in the military, word is everything. In October 2020, Jennifer told Darren that she'd reached her breaking point. She confessed that she wanted Jamie dead and began brainstorming ways to kill him. She considered poisoning him, but was worried what would happen to her and her daughter if she got caught. Darren was shocked by Jennifer's plan and didn't express any interest in getting involved. He even tried to convince her to reconsider. In turn, Jennifer appealed to Darren's sense of duty and honour, commending his protective instincts. It was clear she was trying to get him to carry out the killing instead.
当局，但詹妮弗让他发誓不要这样做。詹妮弗说，如果达伦告诉警察，她会否认一切。达伦承诺他不会背着她做任何事，而在军队里，承诺就是一切。2020年10月，詹妮弗告诉达伦她已经到了崩溃的边缘。她承认她想让杰米死，并开始集思广益杀他的方法。她考虑过毒死他，但担心如果被抓到，她和女儿会怎么样。达伦对詹妮弗的计划感到震惊，并没有表现出参与的兴趣。他甚至试图说服她重新考虑。反过来，詹妮弗诉诸达伦的责任感和荣誉感，称赞他的保护本能。很明显，她是在试图让他去执行杀人任务。
Darren pondered the idea in a facetious and wishful manner while trying to convince Jennifer to simply leave Jamie. She refused to do so, fearful that he would retaliate against her and or her daughter. Darren invited the two women to come live with him in Tennessee, but Jennifer dismissed this possibility, saying that they had to stay in Texas for her daughter's work. It was only when Darren received emails from Jamie warning him of his plans to orchestrate a hot tub gang rape for his and Jennifer's 15th anniversary that Darren started seriously considering Jennifer's proposal. Scared that Jennifer could be killed during this attack, which was planned for the weekend of Friday October 9 2020, Darren was left agonising over what to do.
达伦以一种戏谑和一厢情愿的方式思考了这个想法，同时试图说服詹妮弗直接离开杰米。她拒绝这样做，担心他会报复她和/或她的女儿。达伦邀请这对母女搬到田纳西州和他一起住，但詹妮弗驳回了这个可能性，说她们必须留在德克萨斯州，为了她女儿的工作。直到达伦收到杰米的电子邮件，警告他计划在他们结婚15周年纪念日策划一场热水浴缸轮奸案时，达伦才开始认真考虑詹妮弗的提议。担心詹妮弗会在这次袭击中丧生（计划于2020年10月9日星期五的周末进行），达伦陷入了痛苦的抉择。
He said he didn't settle on a decision until the day before, Thursday October 8. That day, Darren convinced himself that he needed to eliminate the threat to save Jennifer's life. After promising Jennifer that she would never go through another bad weekend again, Darren set out for Texas. The 10 hour drive gave Darren plenty of time to transition back into a military mindset. He hyped himself up, reminding himself over and over that he had to rescue Jennifer and her daughter from Jamie. As he approached the Texas border, his emotions ramped up and he turned off his phone. But once he reached Dallas, he became lost. He drove helplessly among the unfamiliar dark roads with no idea where to go or what to do. Panicking as time was
他说直到前一天，即10月8日星期四，他才下定决心。那天，达伦说服自己，他需要消除威胁以挽救詹妮弗的生命。在向詹妮弗保证她再也不会经历糟糕的周末后，达伦出发前往德克萨斯州。10小时的车程给了达伦充足的时间重新进入军事思维模式。他不断地给自己打气，一遍又一遍地提醒自己，他必须从杰米手中救出詹妮弗和她的女儿。当他接近德克萨斯州边境时，他的情绪高涨，关掉了手机。但当他到达达拉斯时，他迷路了。他在陌生黑暗的道路上无助地行驶，不知道该去哪里或该做什么。随着时间流逝，恐慌感袭来，
running out, the intense emotions triggered Darren's post-traumatic stress disorder and he had a mental breakdown. Overwhelmed and spiralling, he had to pull over to get his bearings. As far as he knew, the love of his life was going to be attacked within hours. His mind was flooded with thoughts of what she was about to endure and the possibility that she could be killed. With the Darren's stress levels peaking, he was plagued by visions of the loved ones he'd lost over the years. There were his military comrades, a close friend who had taken his own life, and Darren's own granddaughter who had drowned while he was on deployment. Darren felt responsible for all these deaths as he wasn't able to prevent them. He'd since told himself that if he was ever in a position to help somebody, he wouldn't hesitate.
强烈的负面情绪触发了达伦的创伤后应激障碍，他精神崩溃了。不知所措且情绪失控，他不得不靠边停车以确定方向。据他所知，他一生挚爱的人将在几小时内受到攻击。他的脑海中充满了她即将遭受的痛苦以及她可能被杀的可能性。随着达伦的压力水平达到顶峰，他被多年来失去的亲人的幻象所困扰。有他的战友，一个自杀的好友，还有达伦自己的孙女，在他部署期间溺水身亡。达伦对所有这些死亡感到内疚，因为他没能阻止它们。此后他告诉自己，如果他有机会帮助别人，他绝不会犹豫。
He remembered an old military saying, it's better to be judged by twelve than carried by six. In other words, it was better to face a jury than wind up in a casket. Darren knew the only way he could get out of his predicament was to turn his phone back on so he could search for directions. He knew this would leave a digital record of his whereabouts and potentially seal his fate, but he felt as though he had no other option. If he returned to Tennessee and Jennifer ended up a dad, he wouldn't be able to live with himself. With that, Darren powered on his cell phone, searched online for South Waverly Drive,
他记得一句古老的军事格言：“被十二个人审判总比被六个人抬着走要好。”换句话说，面对陪审团总比最终躺进棺材里要好。达伦知道他摆脱困境的唯一方法是重新打开手机，这样他就可以搜索路线。他知道这会留下他行踪的数字记录，并可能注定他的命运，但他觉得别无选择。如果他回到田纳西州而詹妮弗最终死了，他将无法原谅自己。于是，达伦打开手机，在线搜索南韦弗利大道，
and followed the map. Once he reached the Faith's house, Darren turned his phone back off. He didn't want to storm the Faith's home and risk any collateral damage. Jennifer had already informed him that the house to the right was vacant, so Darren headed there. He positioned himself against the fence in reconnaissance mode and waited. Jennifer had already told Darren that she and Jamie walked their dog Maggie every morning. At daybreak, Darren listened until he heard the faith's door open. He then heard Jennifer's voice and saw her walk past with Maggie. It was the first time Darren had laid eyes on her since they dated 30 years prior. He then watched as Jamie walked casually by.
并按照地图行驶。到达费斯家后，达伦再次关掉了手机。他不想强攻费斯家，冒着造成附带损害的风险。詹妮弗已经告诉他右边的房子是空着的，所以达伦去了那里。他以侦察模式靠在栅栏上等待。詹妮弗已经告诉达伦，她和杰米每天早上都会遛狗玛吉。天亮时，达伦听着，直到听到费斯家的门打开。然后他听到了詹妮弗的声音，看到她带着玛吉走过。这是达伦自30年前约会以来第一次见到她。然后他看着杰米随意地走过。
Darren acted immediately, shooting Jamie three times in the chest and causing him to fall to the ground. As a military medic, Darren knew the human body could survive significant trauma. Even though he thought Jamie was a monster, he still didn't want him to suffer. He stood over Jamie and shot him three times in the head before shooting him in the groin as payback for the sexual abuse he'd inflicted on Jennifer. Darren stole Jamie's wedding ring to make it look like a robbery gone wrong. He then launched an attack on Jennifer. Darren hadn't forewarned Jennifer of his intentions to do this because he wanted her reaction to be genuine. He thought this would add credibility to the staged robbery while also giving Jennifer plausible deniability. Darren knocked Jennifer to the ground, punching and slapping her before
达伦立即采取行动，向杰米的胸部开了三枪，导致他倒在地上。作为一名军医，达伦知道人体可以承受严重的创伤。尽管他认为杰米是个恶魔，但他仍然不想让他受苦。他站在杰米上方，对着他的头部开了三枪，然后又向他的腹股沟开了一枪，作为对他对詹妮弗实施性虐待的报复。达伦偷走了杰米的结婚戒指，使其看起来像是一起抢劫案。然后他向詹妮弗发动了袭击。达伦没有预先警告詹妮弗他打算这样做，因为他希望她的反应是真实的。他认为这会增加伪造抢劫案的可信度，同时也给詹妮弗提供了合理的推诿空间。达伦把詹妮弗撞倒在地，拳打脚踢，然后
duct taping her hands together. It was the first time they had touched since 1993. Jennifer's blood-curdling screams made Darren sick. He tried to pull off her wedding ring, but it got stuck. That's when he noticed a witness rushing over. It was Emery Wilson, one of the Faith's neighbours. Emery approached Darren and the two made eye contact. Darren was carrying extra ammo and could have killed Emery to protect his own identity, but he maintained his mission of not wanting any collateral damage. Once Emery ran off, Darren got back into his truck. The commotion had drawn several more neighbours onto the street, so Darren drove off slowly, not wanting to accidentally run any of them down. Darren wasn't happy about what he'd done, but was nevertheless satisfied that he'd accomplished
用胶带把她的手绑在一起。这是他们自1993年以来第一次身体接触。詹妮弗撕心裂肺的尖叫声让达伦感到恶心。他试图摘下她的结婚戒指，但卡住了。就在这时，他注意到一名目击者冲了过来。那是埃默里·威尔逊，费斯家的邻居之一。埃默里走近达伦，两人目光交汇。达伦带着额外的弹药，本可以杀了埃默里以保护自己的身份，但他坚持自己不造成任何附带损害的任务。埃默里跑开后，达伦回到了他的卡车上。骚动引来了街上更多的邻居，所以达伦慢慢开车离开，不想意外撞倒他们中的任何一个。达伦对自己所做的事情并不高兴，但仍然对自己完成了
his mission. On the long drive home, he tossed a Jamie's wedding ring out the window. He didn't get rid of the murder weapon because he wanted to make sure it was never used to hurt another person again. While Jennifer pretended to be a grieving widow in public, behind closed doors she was elated that Jamie had been killed. She showered Darren with money, gifts and praise. When Darren was arrested, he took solace in knowing he had saved Jennifer and her daughter. But that all changed once he finally accepted that Jennifer had duped him. Darren was devastated to realise he had taken the innocent life of a proud family man. He was equally shocked that Jennifer would bestow such tragedy on her own daughter.
任务感到满意。在回家的长途车程中，他把杰米的结婚戒指扔出了窗外。他没有处理掉凶器，因为他想确保它永远不会再被用来伤害另一个人。当詹妮弗在公共场合假装成悲伤的遗孀时，在私下里，她为杰米被杀而欣喜若狂。她用金钱、礼物和赞美来奖励达伦。当达伦被捕时，他因知道自己救了詹妮弗和她的女儿而感到安慰。但这一切在他最终接受詹妮弗欺骗了他之后发生了改变。达伦意识到自己夺走了一个自豪的顾家男人无辜的生命，感到万分痛苦。他也同样震惊于詹妮弗竟然会给自己的女儿带来如此悲剧。
He told detectives, Jennifer turned me into a monster. While Jennifer had told countless lies to Darren, he'd only ever lied to her once. His military training had taught him to always have an escape route. He therefore assured Jennifer that he'd deleted all of their communications, when in reality, he'd kept their emails. Following Darren's confession, investigators upgraded the charges against Jennifer Faith from obstruction of justice to murder for hire. This was a federal offence that carried the death penalty. Jennifer maintained her innocence as she was placed in custody pending trial. A month later, she wrote a letter to her father claiming the prosecution and media had twisted
他告诉侦探：“詹妮弗把我变成了一个恶魔。”虽然詹妮弗对达伦撒了无数次谎，但他只对她撒过一次谎。他的军事训练教会他始终要有一条逃生路线。因此，他向詹妮弗保证他已经删除了他们所有的通讯记录，而实际上，他保留了他们的电子邮件。在达伦供认后，调查人员将针对詹妮弗·费斯的指控从妨碍司法公正升级为雇凶杀人。这是一项联邦罪行，最高可判处死刑。詹妮弗在等待审判期间被拘留，并坚称自己无罪。一个月后，她写信给她的父亲，声称检方和媒体歪曲了
the situation and taken things out of context in order to paint a damning picture against her. Yet, just two days after sending the letter, Jennifer was informed that Darum was cooperating with prosecutors and was willing to testify against her. This coupled with the overwhelming evidence dissuaded Jennifer from taking the case to trial. In exchange for the death penalty being taken off the table, she agreed to tell the full truth about her husband's murder.
情况，断章取义，以描绘出一幅对她不利的画面。然而，就在寄出这封信两天后，詹妮弗被告知达伦正在与检察官合作，并愿意出庭指控她。这加上压倒性的证据，使詹妮弗放弃了将案件诉诸审判的念头。作为交换，检方不再寻求死刑，她同意说出关于她丈夫被谋杀的全部真相。
Jennifer admitted that Jamie had never been anything other than a wonderful and loving husband. After learning of Darren Lopez's disability, she'd used fake online identities and misleading images to convince him that she was being abused by Jamie in the hopes that Darren would be compelled to kill. After Jamie's death, Jennifer rewarded Darren with gifts and adoration to keep him on her side and prevent him from exposing her involvement. In the words of one US attorney, Jennifer Faith's conduct both before and after her husband's murder was extraordinarily heinous and cruel. The one person that Jamie Faith loved and trusted more than any other led him to his death. At Jennifer's sentencing in May 2022, the presiding judge criticised her treatment of Darren, stating,
詹妮弗承认，杰米一直以来都是一位出色且充满爱心的丈夫。在得知达伦·洛佩兹的残疾后，她利用虚假的在线身份和误导性的图片让他相信自己正受到杰米的虐待，希望达伦能被迫杀人。杰米死后，詹妮弗用礼物和崇拜来奖励达伦，以让他站在自己这一边，并防止他揭露她的参与。用一位美国检察官的话说，詹妮弗·费斯在丈夫被谋杀前后的行为极其令人发指和残忍。杰米·费斯最爱和最信任的人将他引向了死亡。在2022年5月詹妮弗的量刑听证会上，主审法官批评了她对达伦的对待方式，指出：
He thought he was the only person who could save you. You tricked him because you thought his brain wasn't working. Jennifer's subsequent attempts to sway law enforcement and public opinion were described as spineless. At one point, Jennifer started to cry. The judge told her, Mrs. Faith, I'm not sure why you're crying. What you did was such a betrayal. You are pure evil. Not to mention, disgusting. Jennifer Faith was sentenced to life imprisonment. She was also ordered to pay $6500 in restitution to Jamie's family to cover his unpaid funeral expenses, as well as a $250,000 fine. Outside court, one US attorney remarked, Outside court, one US attorney remarked,
“他以为他是唯一能救你的人。你欺骗了他，因为你认为他的大脑出了问题。”詹妮弗随后试图影响执法部门和公众舆论的行为被描述为“没骨气”。在某一时刻，詹妮弗开始哭泣。法官告诉她：“费斯夫人，我不确定你为什么哭。你所做的是一种背叛。你纯粹是邪恶的。更不用说，令人作呕。”詹妮弗·费斯被判处终身监禁。她还被勒令向杰米的家人支付6500美元的赔偿金，以支付他未付的葬礼费用，以及25万美元的罚款。在法庭外，一位美国检察官评论道，在法庭外，一位美国检察官评论道，
Jennifer Faith put on quite a performance in the wake of her husband's murder. She poured out her sob story to reporters and to law enforcement, then headed home to orchestrate her cover-up. But crocodile tears didn't stop the feds. We were committed to getting justice for Jamie and with the judges in position of a life sentence, we're one step closer. Darren Lopez's murder trial went ahead in July 2023, one year after Jennifer's trial, and almost three years after Jamie Faith was murdered. Given that Darren had already confessed to the killing, it wasn't up to the jury to determine whether he was guilty of murder per se. They just had to consider the degree of his culpability and whether a lesser charge like manslaughter was more applicable. In their
詹妮弗·费斯在丈夫被谋杀后上演了一场精彩的表演。她向记者和执法部门倾诉她的悲惨故事，然后回家策划她的掩盖工作。但鳄鱼的眼泪并没有阻止联邦调查局。我们致力于为杰米伸张正义，随着法官判处终身监禁，我们离目标又近了一步。达伦·洛佩兹的谋杀案审判于2023年7月进行，即詹妮弗审判一年后，距离杰米·费斯被谋杀近三年。鉴于达伦已经承认杀人，陪审团的任务不是确定他是否犯有谋杀罪本身。他们只需要考虑他的罪责程度，以及过失杀人等较轻的指控是否更适用。在他们的
opening statements, the defence told the jury that what they were about to hear was one of the most heart-wrenching and tragic cases anybody's ever heard in this courthouse. While Jennifer Faith wasn't on trial, the defence asserted that she was the real guilty person in this scenario. The crux of their case was that Jennifer had taken advantage of Darren Lopez's disability as well as his feelings for her, which meant she knew which buttons to push. Quote, Darren pulled the trigger, but Jennifer pulled him. Given Darren's past trauma, the defence argued that he viewed danger differently than the average person, and therefore he
开庭陈述中，辩方告诉陪审团，他们即将听到的是这个法院听过的最令人心碎和悲惨的案件之一。虽然詹妮弗·费斯没有受审，但辩方断言她是这种情况下的真正罪魁祸首。他们案件的核心是，詹妮弗利用了达伦·洛佩兹的残疾以及他对她的感情，这意味着她知道该按哪个按钮。引用：“达伦扣动了扳机，但詹妮弗拉动了他。”鉴于达伦过去的创伤，辩方辩称他看待危险的方式与普通人不同，因此他
genuinely believed that Jennifer's life was in immediate danger, which required necessary action. In their opinion, what Darren did amounted to self-defence. The prosecution called this idea absurd and unbelievable. Texas law dictates that an individual can only be justified in using force against another if they reasonably believe the force is immediately necessary to protect themselves in the face of imminent harm. But as the prosecution argued, there was nothing immediate about what Darren did. From the day Jennifer had first confided in Darren about the alleged abuse, 186 days passed
真诚地相信詹妮弗的生命处于直接危险之中，这需要采取必要的行动。在他们看来，达伦所做的是正当防卫。检方称这种想法荒谬且不可信。德克萨斯州法律规定，一个人只有在合理地认为为了保护自己免受迫在眉睫的伤害而立即需要使用武力时，才能证明对他人使用武力是正当的。但正如检方所辩称的那样，达伦所做的一切一点也不“迫在眉睫”。从詹妮弗第一次向达伦吐露所谓的虐待之日起，过去了186天
before Jamie was killed. Darren therefore had plenty of time to consider other, less drastic options. He could have reached out to Jennifer's family, contacted Jamie's employer, alerted the authorities, or helped Jennifer escape. After all, he had the Special Forces training needed to conduct an escape mission without taking any casualties. Darren had considered all of these options in his emails to Jennifer, but the prosecution argued that he glossed right over them. Instead, all he did was email Rob Schmidt, a man he'd never met.
杰米才被杀。因此，达伦有充足的时间考虑其他不那么极端的选择。他本可以联系詹妮弗的家人，联系杰米的雇主，通知当局，或者帮助詹妮弗逃跑。毕竟，他拥有执行逃生任务所需的特种部队训练，而无需造成任何伤亡。达伦在给詹妮弗的电子邮件中考虑过所有这些选择，但检方辩称他直接忽略了它们。相反，他所做的只是给罗布·施密特发了封邮件，一个他从未见过的人。
When Rob didn't do anything, Darren skipped all the other options and jumped straight to murder. It took him 10 hours to drive to Dallas, at which point he laid in wait for five hours before ambushing Jamie Faith. The prosecution asked, what is immediate about that? It has to be immediate. That means now, right this moment, action is needed. Not in a few minutes, not in a few hours, not later today, not this weekend. Right now. A split second decision. Fear of future danger is never enough, and certainly when you have premeditated an execution, there is nothing immediate about it.
当罗布没有采取任何行动时，达伦跳过了所有其他选择，直接跳到了谋杀。他花了10个小时开车到达拉斯，并在那里埋伏了五个小时，然后伏击了杰米·费斯。检方问道：“那有什么迫在眉睫的？它必须是迫在眉睫的。这意味着现在，就在这一刻，需要采取行动。不是几分钟后，不是几小时后，不是今天晚些时候，不是这个周末。就是现在。一个瞬间的决定。对未来危险的恐惧永远不够，当然，当你预谋了一场处决时，它就没有任何迫在眉睫的成分了。”
there is nothing immediate about it. When Darren did act, the prosecution highlighted that Jamie was unarmed, unsuspecting, and had done nothing to provoke Darren. Darren was trained in situational awareness and assessing threats, yet he killed Jamie when he was innocently walking past with his dog and with his wife. His use of force was therefore unnecessary. The prosecution stated, "...the defendant talked a lot about honour. There was no honour in this. This was the most dishonourable thing that a man can do. They argued that even if Darren had been completely misled, it still didn't justify him committing murder. As an elite special forces soldier, Darren was well equipped to conduct reconnaissance to confirm if Jennifer really was being abused. Not only did he fail to do so, he also knew that Jamie was a tech whiz who worked for one of the most regulated industries on Earth. Surely he didn't believe that Jamie would send damning
它没有任何迫在眉睫的成分。当达伦采取行动时，检方强调杰米手无寸铁，毫无防备，并没有做任何事来激怒达伦。达伦受过情境意识和评估威胁的训练，但他却在杰米无辜地带着狗和妻子走过时杀了他。因此，他使用武力是不必要的。检方指出：“……被告谈了很多关于荣誉的问题。这其中没有荣誉。这是一个男人能做的最不光彩的事情。”他们辩称，即使达伦被完全误导，这也不能证明他犯下谋杀罪是正当的。作为一名精英特种部队士兵，达伦完全有能力进行侦察以确认詹妮弗是否真的受到虐待。他不仅没有这样做，而且他还知道杰米是一位技术天才，在地球上监管最严格的行业之一工作。他肯定不相信杰米会发送毁灭性的
evidence of his crimes through a basic email account in his own name. Even with his disability, the prosecution argued there was nothing to suggest Darren lacked the critical thinking skills necessary to question Jennifer's assertions. When asked on the stand why he didn't scrutinise the claims about Jamie's behaviour, Darren testified, I put my faith in Jennifer. As far as the prosecution were concerned, Darren knew that Jennifer's stories of abuse were bogus. The two of them had shared detailed sexual stories, watched pornography together, and bought each other adult toys. They even roleplayed fantasies in which Jennifer was gang raped while Darren watched
犯罪证据，通过他自己名下的基本电子邮件账户。即使有他的残疾，检方辩称没有任何迹象表明达伦缺乏质疑詹妮弗断言所需的批判性思维能力。当在证人席上被问及为什么他不审查关于杰米行为的说法时，达伦作证说：“我把我的信任寄托在詹妮弗身上。”就检方而言，达伦知道詹妮弗关于虐待的故事是虚假的。他们两人分享了详细的性故事，一起看色情片，并给对方买了成人玩具。他们甚至角色扮演了詹妮弗被轮奸而达伦观看的幻想
or participated. Some of these sordid conversations took place immediately after Jennifer confided in Darren about the sexual abuse she was enduring. As the prosecution pointed out, what kind of man would have these types of conversations with the woman he loved if he genuinely believed she was enduring this kind of sexual abuse in real life. They stated, The abuse was the fantasy. They played this out through calls, texts, emails. They were roleplaying. They were enjoying it. It was all part of the fantasy. The violent, graphic nature of this was part of it. While Darren claimed he had made a last-minute decision to kill Jamie, there was an abundance of phone calls and texts between him and Jennifer that couldn't be retrieved. The prosecution believed these communications contained evidence of the pair scheming to
或参与其中。其中一些肮脏的对话发生在詹妮弗向达伦吐露她正在忍受性虐待之后。正如检方指出的那样，如果一个男人真诚地相信他所爱的女人在现实生活中正在忍受这种性虐待，他会和她进行这种类型的对话吗？他们指出：“虐待是幻想。他们通过电话、短信、电子邮件来演绎。他们在角色扮演。他们很享受。这一切都是幻想的一部分。这种暴力、图形化的性质是其中的一部分。”虽然达伦声称他做出了杀害杰米的最后一刻决定，但他和詹妮弗之间有大量无法找回的电话和短信。检方认为这些通讯记录包含了两人密谋的证据
get rid of Jamie well before October 2020. Jennifer had given Darren access to a since-deleted online document titled, Concerns slash Things to be Add, slash done. She had also sent him texts about what time her pool cleaner was expected at the property, along with information about the way in which Texas license plates were displayed on a vehicle. In another text prior to October, Darren told Jennifer, I'm just going to take the freeways." Given that's exactly what he did on the day Jamie was killed, these factors combined painted a very suspicious picture.
在2020年10月之前很久就除掉杰米。詹妮弗曾让达伦访问过一份后来被删除的在线文档，标题为“关注点/待处理/已完成事项”。她还给他发过短信，告知她的泳池清洁工预计到达物业的时间，以及关于德克萨斯州车牌在车辆上显示方式的信息。在10月之前的另一条短信中，达伦告诉詹妮弗：“我打算走高速公路。”鉴于这正是他在杰米被杀当天所做的事情，这些因素结合在一起描绘了一幅非常可疑的画面。
While the defense had made Darren out to be a victim, the prosecution were unconvinced. They told the jury, They told the jury, There are lies and there are stories and there's strange sex and strange love, but there's no defense. There is but one victim here, one victim, Jamie Faith. After three days of testimony, the jury deliberated for just 90 minutes before returning a verdict. For the murder of Jamie Faith, they found Darren Lopez guilty. Speaking anonymously with NBC News after the trial, one juror revealed that they all agreed an innocent person was dead because of Darren's actions. What they couldn't agree on was dead because of Darren's actions.
虽然辩方把达伦塑造成了一个受害者，但检方并不信服。他们告诉陪审团，他们告诉陪审团：“有谎言，有故事，有奇怪的性爱和奇怪的爱情，但没有辩护。这里只有一个受害者，只有一个受害者，杰米·费斯。”经过三天的证词，陪审团仅审议了90分钟就做出了裁决。对于杰米·费斯的谋杀案，他们认定达伦·洛佩兹有罪。审判后匿名接受NBC新闻采访时，一名陪审员透露，他们都同意因为达伦的行为，一个无辜的人死了。他们无法达成一致的是因为达伦的行为。
What they couldn't agree on was the level of punishment he deserved. Darren faced anywhere from five years to life in prison. While the jury accepted that Darren had been manipulated and didn't present an ongoing danger to society, they believed he should have asked more questions and considered alternative options to help Jennifer. Ultimately, the jury settled on giving Darren Lopez 62 years in prison. Following his conviction, Darren Lopez sought help from the Governor of Texas to get a reduction in his sentence. In an exclusive interview with NBC's Dateline, Darren accepted the consequences of his actions but said he deserved leniency because Jennifer Faith was the true criminal and he was just her weapon. He also pointed out that the jury hadn't been fully informed that he'd helped secure justice
他们无法达成一致的是他应得的惩罚程度。达伦面临五年到终身监禁的刑期。虽然陪审团接受了达伦受到操纵且不对社会构成持续危险的事实，但他们认为他应该提出更多问题并考虑帮助詹妮弗的替代方案。最终，陪审团决定判处达伦·洛佩兹62年监禁。定罪后，达伦·洛佩兹寻求德克萨斯州州长的帮助以减刑。在接受NBC《日界线》的独家采访时，达伦接受了他行为的后果，但表示他应该得到宽大处理，因为詹妮弗·费斯才是真正的罪犯，而他只是她的武器。他还指出，陪审团没有被充分告知他通过向警方提供详细供述，帮助确保了正义
against Jennifer by providing a detailed admission to police. Had they known this, Darren believed they might have looked at him more favourably. As of August 2024, his appeal efforts are ongoing. When Jennifer Faith's friends found out that she'd used their fundraised money to pay her husband's killer, they were devastated. The fundraising platform had an anti-fraud policy, and everyone who made a donation was fully reimbursed. Regardless of Jennifer's deceit, the donors regretted nothing. One said, I would do it again if I thought that a neighbour was in need because that's who we are, and we're not going to change because somebody was awful. If nothing else, our actions were a witness that people care. It turned out that some people had been suspicious of Jennifer's actions from
针对詹妮弗的审判。如果他们知道这一点，达伦相信他们可能会对他有更友好的看法。截至2024年8月，他的上诉工作仍在进行中。当詹妮弗·费斯的朋友们发现她用他们筹集的资金来支付她丈夫的杀手费用时，他们感到非常震惊。该筹款平台有反欺诈政策，所有捐款的人都得到了全额退款。尽管詹妮弗有欺骗行为，但捐赠者并不后悔。其中一人说：“如果我认为邻居有需要，我会再做一次，因为这就是我们，我们不会因为某个人很糟糕而改变。如果说有什么不同的话，我们的行动证明了人们是关心的。”事实证明，有些人一直对詹妮弗的行为持怀疑态度。
the outset. Some thought it was strange that Jamie's killer had spared Jennifer's life despite her being a witness to their crimes. Others immediately thought the shooting had all the hallmarks of a hired hit. Those close to the Faiths also found it odd that soon after Jamie's murder, Jennifer cropped Jamie out of her existing profile picture on social media. The Faith's neighbour, Emery Wilson, had also been suspicious of Jennifer. After Jamie's death, Emery was one of the supporters who put his own anxieties aside to accompany Jennifer as she walked her dog. During one walk, Emery offhandedly remarked that he had seen the then yet to be identified gunman. Jennifer immediately stopped in her tracks.
起初，有些人觉得很奇怪，杰米的凶手竟然放过了詹妮弗，尽管她是他们罪行的目击者。另一些人则立即认为这起枪击案具有雇凶杀人的所有特征。与费斯一家关系密切的人也觉得很奇怪，因为在杰米被谋杀后不久，詹妮弗就将杰米从她社交媒体现有的头像中剪掉了。费斯一家的邻居埃默里·威尔逊也对詹妮弗产生了怀疑。杰米去世后，埃默里是那些放下自己的焦虑，陪伴詹妮弗遛狗的支持者之一。在一次散步时，埃默里随口提到他看到了当时尚未被确认身份的枪手。詹妮弗立刻停下了脚步。
Previously unaware of this fact, she abruptly asked Emery if the man seemed black or Hispanic. Emery replied that he couldn't tell as he had only noticed the man's dark eyes. Jennifer didn't press Emery any further, which Emery found strange. He thought she would want to learn all she could to help identify her husband's killer. The situation left Emery with mixed feelings about Jennifer, and he stopped walking with her after that. Jamie Faith's death had a profound impact on his loved ones. A friend of his told ABC News, a friend of his told ABC News, "...not having Jamie in our group definitely left a hole. I just miss my friend." Others felt blessed to have known him, recognising Jamie as a rare find who genuinely cared about others without limit. Jamie was the only real dad his adopted daughter had ever known. The two were incredibly close
此前并不知道这一事实的她，突然问埃默里那个人看起来是黑人还是西班牙裔。埃默里回答说他看不出来，因为他只注意到了那个男人深色的眼睛。詹妮弗没有再追问埃默里，这让埃默里觉得很奇怪。他以为她会想了解所有能帮助确认她丈夫凶手身份的信息。这种情况让埃默里对詹妮弗产生了复杂的情绪，此后他便不再陪她散步了。杰米·费斯的死对他所爱的人产生了深远的影响。他的一位朋友告诉美国广播公司新闻部：“……我们的圈子里没有了杰米，确实留下了一个空缺。我只是想念我的朋友。”其他人则感到能认识他是一种福分，他们认为杰米是一个难得的好人，真心实意地关心他人，毫无保留。杰米是他养女所知的唯一真正的父亲。两人关系非常亲密，
and were described as being joined at the hip. With Jamie gone and her mother in prison, the Faith's daughter moved away from Dallas, taking the family's beloved dog Maggie with her. On their last Valentine's Day together in February 2020, Jennifer gifted Jamie a hardcover book she had created just for him. It was titled, To Thank You For Being You and For Being Mine. A message on the first page read, Jamie, thank you for my wonderful life. This book is a keepsake we can look back at for years to come. I can't wait to celebrate many more Valentine's days with you, my love. The book featured hand-drawn illustrations of the couple along with a list of all the
被形容为形影不离。随着杰米的离世和她母亲的入狱，费斯一家的女儿搬离了达拉斯，并带走了家里心爱的狗玛吉。在2020年2月他们一起度过的最后一个情人节，詹妮弗送给杰米一本她专门为他制作的精装书。书名是《感谢你成为你自己，感谢你属于我》。第一页上写着：“杰米，谢谢你给了我美好的生活。这本书是一个我们可以多年后回味的纪念品。我迫不及待地想和你一起庆祝更多的情人节，我的爱人。”书中收录了这对夫妇的手绘插图，以及一份清单，列出了所有
things Jennifer loved about Jamie, including his generosity, his humour, and the way he always had her back. Jennifer thanked Jamie for appreciating her and always making her feel safe, saying he was the sweetest, most caring partner she could ask for. Jennifer wrote, I hope you feel how much I love you and how grateful I am to have you in my life. One month later, Darren Lopez found Jennifer Faith online. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
詹妮弗爱杰米的地方，包括他的慷慨、他的幽默，以及他总是支持她的方式。詹妮弗感谢杰米对她的欣赏，并总是让她感到安全，称他是她能要求的最好、最体贴的伴侣。詹妮弗写道：“我希望你能感受到我有多爱你，有多感激你出现在我的生命中。”一个月后，达伦·洛佩兹在网上找到了詹妮弗·费斯。目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。